seven
only on CBS mornings we are excited to
reveal Amazon's best books of the year
the Year 2022 drum roll please coming in
at number three stolen Focus why you
can't pay attention and how to think
deeply Again by Johann Harry Hari I'm
getting the eye Hari number two Salito a
memoir by Javier Zamora which tells the
story of his migration to the U.S and
finally Amazon's best book of the year
is the acclaimed novel tomorrow and
tomorrow and tomorrow by Gabrielle zevin
Amazon books editorial director Sarah
Gilman joins us now with more on each of
these books yes uh I'm very excited I
love having you on I love talking about
books this is a wonderful list uh tell
me how it's put together before we get
into more detail okay I love talking
about books too so I lead a team of
editors and our job is basically reading
books and curating them for Amazon
customers every month we put together a
list of the top 10 books of the month
and in October of every year we put all
those lists together we ask ourselves do
we miss anything and then we come up
with the top 100 and you haven't lived
unless you've been in a room with Book
Lovers who are fighting over the top 10
books of the year it is a very
passionate group so that's how we come
up with it it's not based on sales it's
based on books that we love
uh okay so this uh number one best book
of the year tomorrow and tomorrow and
tomorrow you call it perfect for our
moment why and I love the title yeah yes
it's a mouthful but yes so the thing
about this book is it's one of those
books that transcends gender and age and
that's one of the reasons why it's
number one it is a book about two kids a
boy and a girl that meet when they're
kids and they when they grow up they are
co-collaborators and a gaming company
and you sort of think you know boy and
girl meet they're going to fall in love
but the thing that I love about this
book is that's not what it's about it's
actually there's this line in the book
by the female character that says
something like lovers are common but
true collaborators in this life are rare
and it's a book about your earlier
question it's about friendship and
relationships and to me it's one of the
most realistic books about the human
relationship that I've ever read wow
number three on your other stolen Focus
you said it's going to have all of us
rethinking how much time we spend on
social media exactly a lot of us are
doing that yeah I mean just think about
it so you're watching this at home and
you're probably checking emails
yes it is so hard to focus on one thing
and this is what Johann Hari is writing
about and he's looking at tons of
different causes everything from that
like the empty endorphins that you get
when you get a like on social media to
even how we're so taxed physically and
mentally these days to asking our
children to sit in a classroom for eight
hours he's looking at these alongside
his own story about doing a three-month
digital detox and the thing about this
book is first of all you're not going to
feel guilty like we all check those
boxes we're all checking our phone all
the time he doesn't make you feel guilty
but it's also not a self-help book this
is not a like how-to you will get some
tips on how to change your focus a bit
and also it makes you think about the
societal reasons why we all are up this
way now yeah all right so number four an
author not so well known you might not
know him Stephen King he's written a
couple books I've heard published by
Simon Schuster which is division of the
Paramount family so um so what what is
this book and how do you like book is
called fairy tale and I mean you can
look at the jacket the fairy tales that
he's talking about are not the ones that
we tell our children if I see a dog
yes so I think as grown-ups we know that
fairy tales are rooted in this dark
folklore and that's actually the fairy
tale he's interested in so this is
horror mixed with fantasy and it's about
a teenage boy who befriends an older man
and his dog but it takes this dark turn
when the boy just gets the keys to a
secret Magical Kingdom that's ruled by
an evil monster people like Darkness
don't they yes they do yes they do even
King does it very yeah
Darkness I love the darkness you know
who doesn't like Darkness I don't like
horror I'm not a big dog he does it Tony
does I don't either but I like Stephen
King he's a horror fantasy matchup
that's a great combo yeah this is such a
good combo it's like peanut butter and
jelly I'm so bored of the picture books
I'm reading to Teddy every night get
tell me there's a good one on the top of
the kids list yes my kids love this book
it's Night Owl and the premise of this
book is this little owl his lifelong
dream is to become an night and all the
nights in the kingdom are disappearing
and so he's finally called upon for
Night Watch no K on that one and while
he's on Night Watch he finds this
Intruder that's been making all the
nights disappear but this is a very
sweet story it's about friendship and
bravery and there's lots of clever word
play in there to keep adults and kids it
sounds good I don't think there's trains
in it though so no there are no trains
but you've got a number five that you
call the best American novel that's big
that we've read in years yes how did
this make the list with the team decided
this is Horse by Geraldine Brooks the
team decided best American novel we've
read in years wow this is an epic story
it spans centuries and it's all centered
around one of the fastest thoroughbred
horses ever and the black groom who
trained him so
I'm gonna admit I am not one for horse
books and I drag my feet on reading this
book but I started it and I absolutely
loved it you just you have to trust me
in the hands of Geraldine Brooks this
book is totally fascinating Sarah I
Marvel at you every time you come how do
you do this with no notes no notes
there's nothing in the prompter and you
just rattle these off so well and so
coherent how do you do it I talk about
books all the time this is what I do
this is the benefit of reading is what
we're saying yeah brain works that's the
key to relationships hope that you love
someone like Sarah Gilman loves books
there you go all right